president joe biden who some on the left
framed as a neo-liberal war monger
thirsty for wars and colonialism around
the world
wants to completely re-examine and
evaluate
the global troop presence of the united
states and maybe decrease it in some
significant way and
what's interesting about this story it's
not been getting a lot of attention
and it's not surprising to me that it's
not getting a lot of attention because
this is the exact type of story
that does terribly when we talk about it
because the sensible left is sort of
like
yeah we sort of knew that biden wasn't a
bloodthirsty warmonger so this isn't
surprising
the anti-biden left just doesn't want to
hear it because it runs counter to their
narrative
and it's really what the right expects i
mean i i know that the right
under trump cheered this talking point
of trump didn't
start any new wars but it's not actually
their preferred position on foreign
policy the preferred position
of the reactionary right is democratic
presidents
are weak because they don't want to use
the military and they often want to
shrink the military that's the lane
in which the right is most comfortable
critiquing democratic presidents
so the news is to start at the beginning
that the joe biden administration has
launched a
full systemic review of the global
presence of the u.s military
to ensure that it is quote correctly
sized and supports
strategy so at the top that's not the
language
of our military's presence is too small
and we should figure out ways to make it
much bigger
that's kind of the starting point
foreign policy analysts believe that
this is exactly the type of review
that could lead to recommendations to
reduce the number
of bases abroad something i've been
talking about for a decade
reduced the number of troops deployed
around the world now
of course we should all be skeptical
that it will turn
into action given two things number one
given all of the different ways that
republicans can obstruct
uh we have to wonder whether even a
recommendation of reducing the us global
troop presence will turn into into a
reality
on the other hand we've also heard this
from other presidents right i mean we we
heard this from obama
we've even heard it from republican
presidents and rarely
do things change dramatically right now
the u.s has about 800 quote
bases around the world it's an
incredible top line number
the truth is that includes some very
small outposts that
few of us would see a picture of and say
that's a base
all the way up to massive complexes with
thousands of troops
and their families i mean just huge
installations germany is a place where
there are many
there are some in italy many of these
are essentially
vestiges of the cold war that we really
don't need and arguably are a detriment
to american foreign policy
and for me this is not just a moral
issue although it is one
but it's also an economic issue we talk
about tax rates and how
we can afford things that some want to
do
putting aside for a second modern
monetary theory and a more
uh nuanced understanding of debt and
deficit and putting aside the
macroeconomic discussion
the micro of the budget is not trivial
half of american discretionary spending
is on military and defense
so we can talk about tax rates of course
and last week we talked about okay
do should we raise taxes on people
making over four 400 000 or over a
million or over 2 million where should
it be
but imagine without changing anything
about taxation taxation
what we could afford with current tax
revenues
if we change spending priorities and
reduce the amount that we're spending
on defense and the military and without
a doubt that there's
a huge i'll believe it when i see it
component as i mentioned
earlier but this is sort of like a
wow uh uh what what is the truth of
biden's foreign policy and to be clear
this is not a wow biden is the super
progressive on foreign policy
absolutely not that's not what i'm
saying the point here
is just like some on the left insisted
hillary would have started five new wars
and there was really no reason to
believe that that's what would happen
the people expecting biden to do the
same and to grow
the true presence are going to be
disappointed now
joe biden did decide to pause and
re-examine
troop withdrawals that were started or
at least announced by donald trump i'm
talking about
afghanistan and germany where trump said
let's pull out and joe biden got in and
said we're going to pause that
let's wait and see okay because the
position of the biden administration is
essentially
these are my words not theirs but this
is the way i understand it
trump was so incompetent that it's worth
reviewing everything trump was in the
middle of before we decide whether to
continue it
my hope is that biden reviews those two
withdrawals germany and afghanistan
and does this bigger um reevaluation
and says let's continue and then let's
do more
at the same time troops in germany is
far less controversial than many other
deployments
and so i think that the u.s has a
comically high number of bases in
germany
and many of them are completely
unnecessary i don't know that i would
have would have started in germany
necessarily when i think about reducing
our troop spread around the world
doesn't matter the point is we're going
to wait and see what joe biden
actually decides on those two we're also
going to see what the outcome is
of this systemic review of the global
troop presence around the world and
listen i'm not i know some people will
write to me and say david you're so
naive
he's not doing anything the point is
there was a narrative about
biden's going to start all these new
wars he's going to be the neo-liberal
you know dominionist of some kind there
was never any evidence of that
and so far what we're seeing is also not
indicative of that if you disagree with
me let me know you can find me on
twitter at dpakman
and this friday it's finally time
this friday march 26th we are doing a
one-day membership bonanza we're looking
for
massive dumps of new memberships to make
up for a really
crappy february if you want to be
notified
of this one day membership special it's
very easy
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
friday you'll get an email telling ever
telling you everything you need to know
and probably even some things you don't
need to know
one of our sponsors is monk pack
it's tough to get excited about most
granola bars
they have a lot of carbs they don't
taste that great they don't really
satisfy your cravings but monk pack has
something
totally different monk pack keto granola
bars
are sweet and delicious with a soft and
chewy texture
only 140 calories one gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs which
make them work
perfectly for the keto or low carb
lifestyles
they come in excellent flavors like
coconut cocoa chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla
that's my new favorite
i love these because you can just grab
them anytime maybe it's a quick
breakfast an
afternoon snack when you're busy forget
the dry
bland granola bars you've had in the
past try out
monk pack keto granola bars if you don't
love them like i do they'll give you
all of your money back you'll get 20 off
when you go to monkpack.com and use the
coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video